hey guys my name is Tiffany thank you
for joining me you can't see me but I'm
here I decided to do like a little intro
to github how do I post a new project to
github because I realized a lot of
people they're afraid to use the command
line and or at the terminal and they're
also afraid to use get some as a new
developer and you definitely shouldn't
be afraid to use it these are tools that
are gonna make your life easier once you
master them I'm gonna be on my profile
and then I'm gonna go to repositories
and remember this is just to get a new
get this is just to get a new repository
on your github page so when you click on
it you are able to see the code and
everything so this is the process that
we're doing okay so I'm gonna go back to
here go to repositories gonna click new
this part is fine to do on your your
interface it's fine I'm just gonna call
this testing one two three okay and and
you could put a description here testing
github repo it's almost a good idea to
always do that as well as to initialize
what it read me what this readme does is
the readme is basically gonna allow you
the ability others the ability to to
read what's going on before they decide
to want to either make a four career
website or clone it or of this sort
so the readme is important that's where
you put the technologies that you're
using that's what she used to give
instructions to the user if there's
additional instructions so I'm going to
create a repository and now I have a
repo well not really
so what I have now is basically this
readme file that says testing one two
three that's all it is and then here it
has my description that I had okay so
what we're gonna do instead of doing
these we're gonna go through the command
line and do this so what I am gonna do
is I'm gonna clone this so I'm going to
copy this URL so I can put it here so
the command that we're going to use is
git clone and then paste the link and
this is going to clone what we have so
far inside of our repo that we're in and
in this case it's testing one two three
so we're gonna enter okay cool okay
clear this clearing just takes you back
to the top now if I were to LS LS allows
you to list the items that are in this
particular folder and right now we have
a folder inside of here called testing
one two three okay which is the exact
name of our repository now if I wanted
to I could have just created a folder on
my desktop well I didn't have to really
create a folder on my desktop and I
always make that mistake of making a
folder and then making and then cloning
it and then here I have two folders in
here but I don't really need it that's a
common mistake and I still will
sometimes make them at stake as you to
tell so I'm gonna just go into this
testing one two three
so change directory on a Mac it's CD and
then if I LS again it should give me
that readme file that I was looking for
earlier so here is this readme file and
if I wanted to open this readme file
[Music]
yeah I'll just go the add old-fashioned
way add project folder and actually okay
so from our desktop if we just go into
this testing one two there should be a
folder called testing one two three
we should be able to go into that and
then if we LS it's going to show what's
in this folder and it's just that readme
file that's here okay so now I've lost
my atom here it is so I want to use this
one I'm going to open this one and you
see when you open it inside of your text
editor it has like this little link here
this is your github this means it's
connected to github that's what that
means and of course as your dog get
files you can get ignored all those
things and here's your readme file
alright so it has your description in it
for right now
this is basically for future directions
on how to use your app also this is like
ice mentioned earlier earlier this is
where you put the technologies use an
app and I'm just writing this down so
hopefully it'll help you
and then also technologies use an app
and then any like yeah general
directions sometimes if it's a if it's
something where you can participate in
like open source project they'll have
like directions on how to contribute to
open source
so I mean that's another thing that you
can utilize this for so as you can see
it also has changes highlight it off to
the side depending on which text editor
you're using it's going to depend on
what color it is but these just means
that these were added to here to this
file I'm also going to add a new file
and it's just going to be an HTML file
I'm just going to go ahead and save it
and as you can see I'm inside of this
directory desktop 1 2 3 and then here is
the app that I'm in so I'm just gonna
say test dot HTML and everything tests
ok so now we have a new file and then we
also have some changes so if I go back
to my command line and I do a GI T
status I always recommend doing a git
status whenever you're working with git
especially if you get a little lost huh
no pun intended
it'll kind of tell you what to do in
most cases and point you in the right
direction so basically what this is
telling me is that I have some changes
here that I modified I've got a new file
that I've added but it's not in get
right now so it's untracked so it can't
really tell me anything about it because
I don't have it inside of my repo or my
repository and then it says use git add
and or git commit a and so it's
basically telling you what you can do
right and it also says at the top here
you use git add and in the file name and
to update what will be committed okay so
I'm gonna do git add myself personally I
do the period I do get add period and
that adds all the files usually if I'm
at work and there is only one file
there's only one file that I want to be
committed to this particular branch that
I work in branches at work so if it's
only one particular folder I want to add
to this or one file I want to add to it
then I'll just add that particular file
so I would do something like this so I
would copy it and then I'm just going to
paste it right and then you could do the
same thing with this and then paste this
as well so it's basically saying you
want to add test HTML and readme HTML
and then if I enter I can do another get
status okay now instead of red now
instead of being in red like it was up
here it's green which means hey we're
almost there right so these are changes
that need to be committed so if I go
back over here and refresh it's still
not going to show up here inside of my
repo because they're not committed and
they're definitely not pushed so if I do
a git commit dash em always do - em
because that's the message that you're
gonna put on github these messages are
really important when you're when you're
working in a group and they're also
important when you have your own project
because they're kind of like little
reminders of what you did and and -
these files that you're in so it's very
important I used I tell everybody like
make your messages count because one day
you're gonna go back and read them
sometimes mine can get a little crazy
especially while I'm working I'd like to
make sure that I know what what these
files are cuz a lot of times I'm doing
like a feature that's inside of these
files that I'm using or something like
there are updates and I want to make
sure that I'm keeping track of what I'm
updating the whole point of github is so
that you can track your changes and
everything and I feel like if you're not
tracking what you're actually doing like
in an actual message if it doesn't make
any sense
then it's kind of you know ridiculous
really cuz I mean you can go back and
look at the code or whatever but it
makes more sense to go ahead and be like
okay this is what I actually did in a
message rather than reading through all
the files so I added a test HTML file
and updated readme with how to use it
kind of vague but if I go back and look
at this I don't know what I mean okay
now it tells me that it tells me my
message and it also signs it like an ID
number and it tells me that it's on
master master is going to be the branch
that you're on when you first create a
new project when you first create a new
repo and github this master it's gonna
be what you're on if you want to have
another branch which I definitely
recommend doing and we'll go over then
you'll want to create a new branch and
then this will not say branch master
it'll say branch whatever name that you
call it here but that's for a later
video for right now we just want our to
get our project up and to do that we can
use master and this is under the
assumption that you're working on this
project on your own and you haven't
formulated inside of a group yet you
just want your code on github okay so it
told me that I've got two files changed
and it tells me what has been inserted
I haven't deleted anything from these
files if I did it would have told me
deletions as well okay and then if we
want to push this to our page cuz still
fire refresh over here there's still
nothing here it's like oh man it's still
not there so if you do a git push origin
master origin master is going to be the
branch that
we're on in this case like I mentioned
we're on masters so that's what that's
what we're gonna push to and if I enter
it's gonna work its magic which is
basically pushing all of our data up
there and it tells you kind of how long
it takes and what it's doing in the
process which is cool so if i refresh I
said see I should see my files and I do
you see I have my new updates here which
it didn't really look how I thought it
was gonna look but hmm something to
think about and then it has my HTML here
that I had just made so that's how you
do it if you're looking to push up your
project to github this is pretty much
the directions you need in order to do
it if we want to recount what we did we
basically created a new repo in our or
repository in our interface which is
over here and then we got the URL we
cloned it over here let's see I can't go
up yes I can we cloned it here to our
actual machine and then we went through
the process of get status which I told
you it was a big one to use if you ever
get lost and then we basically after
that we we added our files we committed
our files and then we pushed them and
that's pretty much it any other changes
you'll do the same thing you'll add them
and then you could add each individual
file if you want like I did here or you
can do git add a which you won't have to
list them all out and we'll just add
them all for you and then commit and
push that's pretty much it so don't be
afraid of the command-line guys it's
your friend trust me
we're going to be working on branching
creating your own branch and then
pushing up to your branch so branching
is important because when you're working
as a team you'll want to be working on
your own branch so what that means is
you have a copy of whatever is in master
so this would be my master and if I
create a branch then that is mine
right that's my branch just my copy of
master and with that copy of master I
can make my own changes and then push
them up to my branch and then when I get
done say that I'm working on a feature
to add a navigation to the website right
I make my navigation in my branch and
then I do a pull request the team looks
at it okay's it after changes are made
and then it gets pushed to master when
it's in master it's essentially that's
the branch that you want to put into
production you don't want to put your
personal branch into production you want
to put your master branch into
production you want it to be the best
updated copy that you can get right so
right now if I did a git branch I think
I spoke about this in my last video and
by the way I'm gonna link the last video
up in the link description bar if I
haven't already so I'm going to do a git
branch and that's going to tell me what
branches I have and what current when
I'm under so I have a branch called
master which everyone has by default
whenever you create your github repo and
then it's got an asterisk by it meaning
it's the current one and it's green so
that's the current one that we're on I
want to create a new branch in order to
do that I'm gonna do git branch and then
the branch name I'm gonna call mine test
now it doesn't return anything to you
but if you do another git branch now you
have a master and a test pretty cool
pretty
if I want to see if I want to be on that
test branch that I'm gonna do get check
out and then the name of the branch and
it told me that it switched to branch
test if we wanted to check for ourselves
now test is highlighted green and it's
got the asterisks by it now another good
thing is that when you are inside of
your text editor and it's hooked up to
your github it'll tell you this one's a
little small you may not be able to see
it but at the bottom it says hey I'm on
my test branch if I moved back very
quickly Chum tells me I moved to master
and if I go here it switched back to
master so that's kind of a good
indication that you are on the right
branch believe it or not I used that all
day making sure I'm not making updates
to the master branch and pushing things
up that aren't supposed to be pushed up
yet although I haven't made that mistake
before but hey it happens so we are in
our test branch what I'm gonna do oh I'm
gonna go here and I'm gonna refresh as
you can see nothing that's happened
we got one branch still no changes I'm
going to make a change
while I'm in test see I'm on my test
branch and remember I said something
about the navigation so we're gonna add
to our navigation and this project that
I'm working with is for a old YouTube
series I did with HTML and CSS it's just
a basic HTML CSS website if you want to
check that out I'll link that in the
description bar above and you can check
that out so I'm just gonna add a list
item tag and it's gonna just say test in
it that's it so now I'm gonna do a git
status all right so now we have some
things it tells me that I have some
change
a file has been modified and these
changes are not committed which means
they're not saved which means they are
not on my branch they're not saved to my
branch so to speak so I'm going to save
them to my branch because I want to
record this change because it's an
important change for my project so I'm
going to do get ad copy this paste it
the next thing is get commit and I'm
kind of running through this because I
did this in the last video this message
is just going to say add it link to NAV
push I mean enter and then I'm going to
push this change origin and instead of
master I'm going to do test test is the
name of my branch which means that if
your branch is called honky-dory
then you want to say git push origin
hunky-dory so it's pushing my changes to
this branch now if I go over here we
noticed some changes happening when i
refresh this real quick
now it says I have two branches whereas
before it said I only had one so if I
click on it it now shows this test
branch is my branch and it's an active
branch okay and then it also shows me
hey you just recently pushed to this do
you want to make a pull request and
that's what it says here so we'll go
over that later so like I said the point
of a branch is so that you could work on
your changes make your mistakes before
you push them up to master another thing
I didn't mention about branching is
naming your branch so if I wanted to
name a branch name is test here whatever
you want to name it
you could have underscores you can have
dashes if you wanted to you can do camel
case as well and then if I enter
that's just create the new branch
they need but you see here this is now
now my branch name but you don't want to
have it you probably won't want to have
a mix of camelcase
dashes and underscores but if you want
to just name your branch name underscore
is test all lowercase that's probably a
better practice or if you want to say
name is test camelcase
then that's a another good thing to do
and what I'm talking about is like this
get branch name is test so you could do
that or you could do name - is - test
all lowercase with dashes in between or
you can just do underscores name is
underscore test so that's another way to
do it if you'd like I'd say stay
consistent with whatever you're going to
use with your branch names you don't
want to have them all someone camelcase
some of them dashes some of them
underscores it gets to be a little crazy
to look at
so what we're going to do now is we're
gonna do a pull request at this point so
we've got our code up onto github so far
we've created a branch we know how to
name our branch now we want to make a
pull request and have others review it
alright so let's get started I'm already
in my terminal here I'm in the correct
folder that I'm in and I've got my
github up and I've also got my webpage
up here if I want to make a pull request
on the branch I just go here to branches
sometimes it'll show up on that main
page and yellow if there's been recent
changes but for mine it didn't show up
but this is another way that you can
make a pull request so you just click
over here new pull request okay and it
has right here this is the commit
message that I had and if I want to I
could add additional things in this here
box I can say this is normally where you
would put a more descriptive description
of what it is you accomplished with this
branch and pull request also if you have
any additional screenshots that you'd
like insert them here just to kind of
give you as much information about what
happened as you can possibly can
remember this is what's going to be live
right so when you're making a pull
request you're basically saying this is
as best as it's going to be and I want
you to review this so we can make this
change live that's what this is and if
you haven't already you could assign
yourself to this you could assign others
if you're in a group
as well you can request someone to
review it those types of things
labels projects milestones they've got a
lot of things in here to keep you
organized create pull requests
all right great so all it has is my
commit message here the number the
number of pull requests that it is this
happens to be number three and then it
has my description if I had any
additional information now you could
easily since there's no conflicts you
could easily just say merge pull request
but there's really no fun in doing that
and it's really not the right way of
that you would like to practice on doing
this so I am going to click command line
instructions and it basically gives you
the entire instructions on what you need
to do
okay so I'm just gonna go through and
follow the directions it's going to
fetch the origin which is going to fetch
the the main part of this branch which
is technically your master the second
thing you want to do is you want to
check out the branch that is on this
master
and it's going to tell you that that you
have now switched to this new branch
from your origin the next thing is get
merged master so you're getting the
latest changes from master everything's
already up-to-date on my end so I didn't
need to make any changes sometimes your
branch is behind so you just want to get
the latest changes from there if I go
over here I now see that I am on test
down here hopefully you can see that and
then also now I have a list item called
test and if I were to go over here and
refresh my page now I have test as a
link it doesn't go anywhere I didn't
tell it to so it's just a link here okay
so I've checked it out everything checks
out all right this is something I want
to merge into my project or the final
piece of project and I'm gonna do that
now now if I haven't said so already I
do recommend that you have somebody else
on your team look over your pull request
you really shouldn't be reviewing your
own pull request it doesn't really make
any sense for you to do so you did the
work so you don't want to look over your
own work you have you need a second pair
of eyes to do so so with that being said
I want to merge these changes so I'm
going to get checkout master and now I'm
switched to master and if I wanted to
check that it now shows that master is
here and I'm no longer on test now this
is the piece that's important this is
what merges your branch right here now
you may see them show up here honestly I
never make a commit message here because
that's what it's telling you to do I'd
honestly never do that because I already
had the message I want
up here that's descriptive enough for me
there might be a reason for this if it
is I'm not sure but I normally just :
queue to get out of them and to take me
back to my text editor and this tells
you the changes that were made in the
files that were updated the very last
thing you need to do is just push this
into your master branch and that's
working its magic it's writing things
it's adding things to your master and
it's done
so if I go back here that message this
git push origin master basically merged
my branch into master and it's telling
me now that it's merged which is great
which means I'm done you could delete
the branch from here if you'd like or
you could delete it from the terminal I
recommend doing it from the terminal
we'll do that in a second
so this is it now if you click on pull
requesters no more if you go back to
your code it now has your added link to
nav bar message here and if you click
into it you can see that as well if you
were to refresh you should still see
test because it's now merged in the
master and we are on the master branch
and everything is up to date so that is
all you do if you wanted to delete this
branch after you're done with it you
don't want it anymore you don't want to
see it when you do get branch all you
have to do is get branch the name of the
branch dash capital D get rid of that
how you do get branch again it is gone
so that's it guys